[Music]
you're listening to inside of you with
Michael Rosenbaum uh hey Jason nelkin
our editors here what's up guys Jason
Elkin here the editor Jason it's good to
see you good to see you man it's always
a pleasure to come in and record these I
called you this morning and I said Jason
where I go I got oh man I was up
late I had a friend's birthday last
night I just definitely have another
friend's birthday tonight yeah that's
mine yeah that's my gathering it's not
an actual birthday right but it'll be
fun it's a birthday event yeah Buca di
Beppo Buca di Beppo I love you know I
love Olive Garden I love Buca di Beppo
oh I love it you know my buddy James
Gunn was making fun of me he's like
really I'm like yeah it's fun I like the
food I like I like the food I like the
the camaraderie not camaraderie the uh
what's the the family it's a family
atmosphere it's fun it's light we've got
the back room Georgina and Amy thank you
for hooking me up at the back room I
also took my grandmother there for her
95th in Florida we had the Buca room and
it was a blast man it was just fun like
it's not too stuffy you know it's like
oh I'll have the creamless chiffon owned
and everybody knows what they want yeah
man it's like I want some spaghetti and
meatballs some garlic bread a big salad
with extra olives a large soda trying to
ease off the sodas though yeah it's
tough It's just like Mama used to make
yeah just let Mommy used to make Buca di
Beppo just like mamick used to make
that's right just like ma'am uh great
show for you today
um first a few things the inside of you
online store we've got one of these cool
uh Smallville busts of Lex Luthor
available and a bunch of other stuff go
to the inside of you online store Lex
Miss Scripps signed by me tumblers uh
Lex Luthor Funko Pops there's some
there's some more Lex statues and a
bunch of inside of you stuff so check
that out inside of you online store
um
what else the handles are at inside of
you podcast on Facebook and Instagram
and Twitter's inside you pod
so follow us it really helps the podcast
when you listen not only but you uh
write a review And subscribe and tell
your friends where we've been hanging
around here Jason this little podcast
has been hanging around and you know
it's been a good year
um you know a lot of slow years man of
like geez should I be doing this but uh
it's been picking up a little I hope it
continues and um I really sincerely
thank everybody for listening if you
want to contribute uh Patron join
patreon patreon
p-a-t-r-e-o-n.com inside of you become a
patron today I'll send you a message top
tiers get a bunch there's a lot of perks
I send boxes and I you know I write
little notes and it's become a nice
family
and uh if you're a patron listening by
the way my buddy Robert Brandenburg
uh Brandenburg is a patron and he's got
a coffee shop and his mom had passed
away and he opened a coffee shop so he's
been having some tough time so if
anybody wants to fellow patrons go to
um you know messaging maybe and um
Brandenburg Brandon did I say it wrong
Brandenburg I think it's Robert
Brandenburg well if I screw that up I'm
sorry I don't know where my mind is
today but uh it's called Peggy Peg's
coffee shop or Peggy's I gotta remember
now I'm blank but I'm I'm giving you
credit my patrons will all look it up
it's in um it's it's a great place and
the great coffee he sent me some coffee
before
um so Patron also Tom and I will be uh
in Montreal this weekend we're doing a
Smallville nights Kristen Crook's gonna
be there some other cast members it's
going to be a blast in Montreal if
you're close in the area in the vicinity
sun's been the new vinyl is out
sunspin.com it's autographed there's
only like a hundred available and we've
sold a ton already get them they're
awesome we're so pumped Jason are you
gonna be close to Montreal Montreal not
this weekend my friend damn do you know
there was a place called Dildo
Newfoundland that's wild yeah different
language though so maybe you mean
something different to that Carrie
Fisher once sent me a postcard and says
greetings from dildo love Carrie that's
amazing it was amazing I have it I kept
it I kept a few things that she gave me
over the years also do you listen uh to
my podcast on Stitcher
I got bad news Stitch was going away on
August 29th so go to another app please
and listen listen in another app look
for us on Apple Spotify YouTube
Stitch is going bye bye great guest Sean
Williams Scott uh look I don't know if
you know this but Sean is in an absolute
gem
such a good dude um he's got a new movie
The Wrath of Becky it's it's a Revenge
movie it's a bloodbath it's fun it's
intense uh I think everybody should see
it uh Lulu Wilson's in it and I also
think Sean produced that I also love the
movie goon which we talked about he did
goon 2 as well uh love goon uh American
Pie we talk about we talk about life we
talk about a little depression I
appreciate everybody listening and uh
let's you know Jason
let's I think we should get into this
let's get into it let's get inside of
Sean William Scott it's my point of view
you're listening to inside of you with
Michael Rosenberg
[Music]
inside of you with Michael Rosenbaum was
not recorded in front of a live studio
audience what's it good to see you man
now I don't you know
I we met I know we've met a couple times
but like how long how long I've been
thinking the same thing as like I know
we've met but um I was like
when and it was definitely a long time
ago
um yeah so yeah it probably had
something to do with either the WB
yeah
CW or something but back in the day I
was probably doing small but I think you
were doing happily ever after or
something you did an episode or
something did you
yeah but wait that's when we met that
was 25 years ago dude I'm telling you
I'm telling you
and I remember this work by the way
Unhappily Ever After dude you should see
some of my work on Zoe Duncan Jack and
Jane that was some work
or the Tom Arnold show that really did
it now look I'm very grateful and it was
awesome but I looked back
and I was just talking to Vincent
D'Onofrio name drop and I was just
talking to him about this
and he was like he was looking at some
of his old work and he was like
what this idiot look at you look
at him just like in his interviews all
over the place he's like who are you
it's the uh and I'm like well that's who
you were then he's like I know I know
but
wait is he so he's he like will watch
he'll still watches old stuff and just
get down on himself could you imagine
Vincent D'Onofrio by himself in his
house just watching old clips of himself
I can't imagine three TV screens just
like everything's just playing at a loop
from all of his old work he's like
you suck there
and intensely intensely now what do you
what because I was doing my impression
of him on um Law and Order Criminal
Intent and he's just he's freaking
unbelievable like he brings it I
remember watching it and going
I was just going through channels like
oh I like Vincent an opera what's this
oh it's Law and Order and then you hear
him go
um yesterday you
there was this thing you were
and he was doing this thing and I'm like
oh my God I can't stop watching him and
then he talks yeah that's a really good
impression of him that was awesome it
was kind of like I fluctuate because
it's a little Malkovich too now what you
couldn't know Sean William Scott is that
you know he does this thing I do it all
the time people are probably shut the
up and talk to Sean well yeah Jesus
um thanks for being here man man thanks
for having me on this is great I I've
wanted you on this for a long time you
were one of those guys
that always made me laugh and just I'm
happy for your success but I have to be
honest I was envious jealous I was going
up for a lot of the roles Dude where's
my car and all this and you got it
and I was like God he's better looking
that's why that's not true and by the
way you would have been way better at
all I had no idea I you know how it is
it's like you just focus on just trying
to get a job and then you know you get
it and you just do the best you can you
forget about like
all the other actors who had been way
better playing the part but no no no you
the thing is with you is you commit you
you like go for it balls out whatever
you're doing and what I love is like and
I don't want to talk about this is the
wrath of Becky which you know you're
promoting and a lot of times I always
tell a guests I'm like sometimes I I
don't even want to talk about because
I'm like I didn't like something or I am
it's hard for me to be honest you know
or hard for me to lie but um or I'll do
it in a very cool way where it doesn't
come across I'll be like oh man this is
like but this
I couldn't stop watching to the point
where I I was like writing down things
that really cracked me up and when it's
dark as this is dark man
thank you I yeah I'm really it is one of
those rare movies for I'm actually like
excited and proud to talk about it but I
I was gonna say by the way thank you so
much I'm so grateful that you liked it
because it would be awkward I no I know
what it's like because I
um I remember a story
um I was at a premiere I don't want to
say the movie Just because of people
that ruin it and I want to yeah but
um it was at the Mann Theater in
Hollywood and
um it was so bad the movies I mean in
the movie's so bad I had my family in
town for it oh boy um and then and it's
just like the energy in the theater was
terrible you could just tell everybody
was embarrassed
but then afterwards the worst part
um is at the party people didn't know
what to say so you really know when
somebody genuinely didn't like your
movie it was when they usually say like
it looked like you had a lot of fun
making it oh or if they go like so what
do you have coming up next you know yeah
so I'm glad this makes it less awkward
for both of us that you actually like
well I call it fun comfortable that's
what we call it I call it fun
comfortable
that's kind of like you know it's like
it's I've been in those situations and
I've told this story but Ryan knows that
he always looks at me goes uh-huh yeah
my Brian's here
um but I did this one movie and my buddy
Dax Shepard came to the movie and he's
in the screening and I had to sit with
some other no yeah he was sitting like
four people over for me and I had to sit
with somebody else and
he texts me in the middle of the movie
and I was looking at my phone because I
wasn't that interested really in the
movie and he says but this movie's so
bad I can't believe I'm not in it
that's awesome
um a lot of fun comfortable movies by
the way yes I mean it's just it's par
for the course and you know it's kind of
sad there's a sad element because when
you're a kid
or a teenager or aspiring actor you're
like I just want to work I want to do
something I don't you don't care about
Fame as much or about success of the of
a movie or a show you're just like I
just want to work I want to be a working
actor and then you do a project
and it's not enough it's not enough that
you made a movie and you got paid for it
and it actually was in a theater or on
screen but now you're thinking oh it
didn't do well so that's not good or or
I wasn't good or so it's like all these
exterior these things that you can't
control when the kid inside of you just
wants to go I'm in a movie but you're
thinking yeah you know what I mean how
do you how do you deal with that have
you did you have any problems with that
growing up like when you first got your
first I mean you've been through it
you've done commercials you worked at
where did you work you worked at the
Home Depot you were in the LA Zoo I had
a bunch of like odd jobs I mean but to
be honest like I was you know obviously
so lucky because
um moved out to LA when I was about 18
and then I I mean it was about three
years later that I got American Pie so
it was obviously like winning the
lottery and then but I think to be
honest like even you know every every
project that I was lucky enough to do
even when they were stinkers I was is
always
you know so in one hand you're like hey
I can't believe I got a chance to make a
movie it sucks the movie's garbage but
I'm like but I I always I never lost
perspective there was always you know so
there's that but then there's also the
fear like how is this gonna damage me
like am I gonna get another opportunity
so so I never I I think I always had
that the kind of like little kid
excitement I still do where it's like
I can't believe and still get a chance
to do this but for sure
um
man it's painful when they're bad
this little part of you dies inside or
how about the
but what about the movies that you watch
and you go I think this is kind of funny
or I think I'm kind of good and then but
you don't ever receive that you know the
reviews are bad no one wants to talk
about it you're like I did a movie
called sorority boys and I was like I'm
proud of that movie it was I thought it
was really funny and my uncle who hates
everything and he liked it but it wasn't
well why doesn't everybody else like it
no I know there's a couple of those
um that I've done where
yeah then you have to walk away like
think I think pretty good nobody watched
it like apparently like what does that
say about me I think it's good everybody
else thinks it's kind of bad yeah you
start to question yourself I mean which
then you start asking questions you
start questioning yourself you're like
am I that good maybe I'm not that good
have you ever done something where you
you watch and you're like I'm
great in your head you're like I'm
you won't say it out loud except
for you're like your girlfriend your
wife or your best friend but I'm
good in this and I feel good about this
and then
no one's given you the praise that you
go I just are you kidding me
could anybody see this apparently if
you've never had that no I'm too hard on
myself I yeah I I have a hard I think in
the beginning of my career it was just
you know it was more
um like you know sitting in the theater
and and trying to figure out like what
worked you know in the comedies like
what improv worked and then when it did
work it um
you know it was really rewarding most
the time from the beginning until now
it's like I'm I'm really hard myself I
usually yeah I've never I wish I could I
wish I could watch something be like you
did a good job Sean I've never been like
you're great see now you make me
feel like an no no no no no no
I'm kidding I'm kidding no look it's not
like everything I do ago I'm
awesome I'm awesome I'm great
I'm saying look I'm like here's if I had
to watch my resume I go
yeah
I'm like
yes oh yeah all right that's kind of
like you know sort of the through line
yeah well that and that's okay it's
healthy but it's also
I think probably healthy to go hey
you know you're good you're good you did
that's the part you played and you
played it the best that it could be
played you didn't know I think
inside he was brought to you by rocket
money don't go anywhere right now
because I'm gonna save you money
guaranteed just this is a no-brainer we
all have apps and things that you know
subscriptions that we get and um because
we want to see a show on some random
platform and then we forget to cancel
our subscription and those rack up
monthly and all of a sudden it's like a
hundred two hundred dollars at the end
of the year for all your unwanted
subscriptions
rocket money will help you
it's that easy rocket money is a
personal finance app that finds and
cancels your unwanted subscriptions
monitors your spending helps you lower
your bills all in one place I love these
guys they help me it sounds sometimes
like pocket change to many well 4.99 big
deal it adds up over 80 percent of
people have subscriptions they forgot
about and chances are you're one of them
like that stars app
just to watch one show or that free
gaming trial you never actually used
rocket money will quickly and easily
find your subscriptions for you and for
any you don't want to pay for anymore
you hit cancel let's say you just that
little button cancel and Rocket money
will cancel it for you that easy over 80
percent of people have subscriptions
they forgot about you could be wasting
money and not even realizing it rocket
money helps you find those forgotten
subscriptions so you can stop paying for
ones that you don't use yeah most
Americans think they spend around 80 a
month on subscriptions you know eighty
dollars the actual total is closer to
two hundred dollars if you don't know
exactly how much you're spending every
month you need rocket money rocket money
also helps you manage your finances in
one place and automatically categorize
your expenses so you can easily track
your budget in real time and also get
alerted if anything looks off
over three million people have used
rocket money saving the average person
up to 720 a year stop throwing your
money away cancel unwanted subscriptions
and manage your expenses the easy way by
going to rocketmoney.com inside that's
rocketmoney.com inside
rocketmoney.com
inside this show is sponsored by
betterhelp sometimes in life we're faced
with tough choices and the path forward
isn't always clear whether you're
dealing with decisions around your
career your relationships or anything
else therapy helps you stay connected to
what you really want while you navigate
life so you can move forward with
confidence and excitement
trusting yourself to make decisions that
align with your values is like anything
the more you practice it the easier it
gets if you're thinking of starting
therapy give better help a try
it's entirely online so it's convenient
flexible and suited to your schedule
just fill out a brief questionnaire to
get matched with a licensed therapist
and switch therapists anytime for no
additional charge let therapy be your
map with better help visit
betterhelp.com inside today to get 10
off your first month that's better help
betterhelp.com slash inside
even when things are bad I'm like I did
the best that I could but by the way it
would be such a great character I'm sure
maybe it's somebody that already created
it but that's I'm the great guy
who's every he's like that's I'm
awesome I'm hey I'm
awesome like just I'd love to see
that character it seems like it's almost
like Ben Affleck in in Dazed and
Confused without saying that yes he was
sort of that guy who's like yeah
yeah awesome I'm this
you know and nobody wanted to hang out
with that guy nobody wants to hang out
with a guy who thinks he's great at
everything you know what I mean just be
great and if people see it then just be
humble about it you know go home and go
yes
you know I think that's the way
celebrate yourself in privacy right do
you do you uh
do you ever get so because you don't
like watching yourself do you ever get
depressed or have you been depressed
from something not doing as well as you
thought you worked so hard in a movie
you're a TV show or whatever
and you get depressed for like a long
period of time and you're like yeah I
don't know how to get out of it and what
do you do about it like it really
affects you I think that it always had a
pretty good idea before you know you
kind of get us you know if if you're
paying attention even when you're making
it you kind of have an idea of like I
don't know I don't I don't I have low
expectations for this so I I haven't had
that experience probably just because I
I feel like I've had a pretty good idea
before something's come out whether it
kind of works or not right
no I I mean certainly been some movies
where like
well I mean that movie that I was
telling you about it the the premiere I
remember my brother came up to me at the
at the after party and he's like dude
why did you make that movie you
son oh I took a time off of work to come
for this I can't get that time back and
I was like you dude how many movies
have you made that's what I was gonna
say you brother what kind of
brother are you anyway yeah it
was terrible it was a terrible movie but
you know I I can't like I I look at you
like I wasn't popular at all in high
school I was a nerd I talk about at Ad
nauseam but like I look and I see that
you know you played football you played
Sports you're pretty you're pretty
popular right for the most part I was
like I wasn't like the cool guy but I
was I had a lot of great friends yeah
right so you think with some success in
high school whatever Sports this and
that and you got some confidence you
know people tend to
um you know you could fall into that
like cocky and I never have
heard anything bad about you like it's
always he's such a really good guy he's
a nice guy he's like that's important
you know I always hear that and so is
that in something that's embedded in you
when you're growing up is it something
that your parents you give credit to
your parents for raising you what was
that like growing up yeah I might you
know the funny thing is is like also I
grew up in Minnesota and I've always
said like you know the biggest
in Minnesota is one of the nicest people
you've ever met like people are just
really nice there but um for the most
part there's some dicks I'm sure but um
Nick swords Nick Swardson he's a
dick no I'm kidding he's one of my
buddies he's a good dude yeah yeah I got
my parents I mean my mom is so so nice
I've always said she's like the most
selfless you know amazing person so they
yeah I was really lucky to have great
parents and
um
I think that's it and also thinking with
again it's like with what we get it to
do
um you know I it's I became an actor
because I just love movies it was
literally that I actually have another
so I'm the youngest of seven half
brothers and sisters it was like The
Brady Bunch and like
um I actually have a different brother
who was the actor of the family so he's
probably like really secretly angry with
me because I've chose to do this and
I've had a chance to do it but he's
actually been supportive but
um
why did I bring oh yeah why did I bring
that up because I was talking about how
you know your parents were real you know
your mom was really good you know
growing up and what Ryan yeah sorry but
yeah completely Ryan oh you're gonna
talk about uh watching movies oh thank
you oh yeah yeah you love movies thank
you Ryan for listening and wow what's
wrong with me
um uh I need somebody like that
you know like off camera all the time
just to help me when I'm like forgetting
yeah sometimes I'll go Ryan he's
not even in the house he's like not
working I need you
I love movies my my
um and and
like what drove me to pursue acting was
literally just like I wanna make people
feel the same way that I feel when I see
a great movie it was and I was obviously
very naive I had no experience other
than just being a crazy movie fan so
then when it happened for me
um
it was just like I I I've never I have
always known how lucky I am and in fact
like I've always wanted to give back
even more just because I'm like I can't
believe I get to do this so I think they
also you know I wanted to make sure that
people I've worked with knew that
because you know there's a lot of dicks
out there and a lot of people who like
lose perspective and they don't
understand how lucky we are to go and
make a movie yeah you know you know you
remind me of like the essence because I
worked with them and I think he's like
he's just a great dude and he's a big
movie star and he never makes you feel
like you're any lesser than him is Chris
Pratt
I'm looking at you why I'm like oh he
could have been like uh Star-Lord in the
Guardians I bet you tested for that I
tested for it I wasn't handsome enough
but like I did you didn't test for it
you wouldn't yeah you would have been
great too he was great but I could see
you like testing for something like that
that would be yeah that's I've never met
Chris but um that's a huge compliment I
appreciate it uh
yeah
um somebody actually asked me a question
about
about the only audition I ever had for a
comic book movie and it literally I
think it was Spider-Man but it wasn't
for Spider-Man it was like
I remember it was a smaller part it's a
long time ago and I literally just
walked in
and
and they they saw me and they're like
thank you so much for coming really
appreciate it I'm like I didn't even get
a chance to sit down dude that was it
that was my audition I was like cool
thank you so much I guess that's it that
was my there was my superhero audition
do you do you ever
um do you let things go do you like I'm
you probably don't audition a ton now
but like when you did audition did you
get do you get nervous in auditions do
you do you get nervous on set are you
nervous on Seth for the first few takes
do you like when you until you get into
the Rhythm are you feel that do you
pressure definitely auditioning man it
was like I was a it's funny I was like
98 of the auditions I was just awful and
but it was the like the darker roles
um early on where I did better and I got
closer to getting those parts but but I
always had that kind of athletes
mentality where I was like
all right if you do the best that you
can
but then you know that's all that
matters so I I think that I felt less
rejection that way it was like did I do
it did I do the best I could you know
but a lot of it too was also just the
stressing getting to auditions because I
didn't have a car
so I was taking buses everywhere you
know like trying to figure out the bus
routes and stuff like that so by the
time I got to the audition I didn't give
a about the audition I was starting
to stress out about how to get home but
but yeah I get nervous I get nervous
every day in a set like it it the actual
like process of making a movie for me is
so stressful
um yeah me too because I want to feel
like I did everything I could and I'm
just so relieved by the time that I'm
done because I'm like all right I did I
did everything I could and
um sometimes obviously it's enjoyable
when things are working or if you're
doing a comedy and like some of the
Improv works but no I get I get pretty
nervous before every day it's funny you
say that about serious Parts where you
were like doing really well with those
those auditions
and uh for me you know I was doing all
these comedies and this and that I did
this little part in this Clint Eastwood
movie and you know people recognized not
nobody in public recognized me but I'm
saying like agents or managers and
things like that were like just for my
little seven minute scene they're like
oh this maybe he's an actor and
um I didn't audition for many serious
roles just because they they saw me and
met me and they're like oh he's funny
he's outgoing he's uh he's gonna be that
guy and
it really wasn't until I auditioned for
the Lex Luthor part that they started to
see me in a different light they're like
wait a minute and for me I always say
drama is a lot easier for me even though
I love comedy and I love doing it I feel
like I I you know I'm not terrible at it
but I you know but I did seven years of
that and then of course they think you
as oh he's the serious guy and then then
you have to be funny again and it's like
the cyclical thing yeah but I
know what it's like um I put so much
pressure on myself and I'm guessing
that's what you do is you want to be
great you want everybody to like you you
want everybody to say hey he's doing the
job he's nailing the part um and I think
that's a good quality to have but you
know for me it became a little
debilitating at times because I would
just it's too much I'm thinking about it
too much I'm stressing about it too much
and uh did it get that bad for you or
can you let it go yeah I think that's
just my process and I'm sure a lot like
yourself like there's a lot of you know
other actors that's it's how it's just
you just have to accept this is what
what drives me and I think
um like especially for comedies too
because it you know I never really set
out to do comedies I never I have a good
sense of humor I like to laugh my family
I mean you grew up in Minnesota like you
have to have a good sense of humor it's
cold as up there like
um great place to grow up but it is cold
and but I think that with comedies
especially because I would like to
improvise and I would you know go to the
set you know and some of these comedies
and have a bunch of different ideas and
then those ideas would you know create
like other ideas and
so
and then the pressure being like
you know this is a movie I I want I just
know I can't have any regrets I can't
walk away feeling like I could have done
better I could have I should have you
know trusted myself and done like this
idea it's uh yeah I realize that's
that's just kind of how it's going to be
for me you know and then afterwards and
especially when it works then you're
like you know I remember in the
beginning like with American pies and
some other comedies when it works and
you're sitting in a theater and you're
hearing people laugh at it it's like oh
it was worth the stress here's all it
was worth the you know the self-portrait
this message is sponsored by discover
did you know you could reduce the number
of unwanted calls and emails with online
privacy protection the latest Innovation
from discover discover will help
regularly remove your personal info like
your name and address from 10 popular
people search websites that could sell
your data and they'll do it for free
activate in the Discover app see terms
and learn more at discover.com online
privacy protection inside of you is
brought to you by wondery Gabrielle
Union strive for the Perfection her
father always demanded but as a
dark-skinned black girl she never felt
like she was enough even the rich is a
podcast from wondery that tells the
jaw-dropping stories about the
tumultuous lives of the world's Elite
from the greatest family dynasties to
pop culture Superstars their newest
season is all about the Teen Movie icon
Gabrielle Union after spending her
childhood trying to assimilate and
breaking into historically racist
industry Gabrielle thought her success
meant someone else had to fail but when
she's faced with hard choices Beyond her
control she realizes that the only way
to find real success is to come together
and build community
host Brooke and orisha will take you
through her life how she shook off her
need for Perfection found her true self
and created the life she always wanted
follow even the rich wherever you get
your podcasts you can listen ad free on
Amazon music or wondery app
um and back to uh the movie The Wrath of
Becky I I just want like this movie uh I
want you guys to watch this I would not
tell you to watch something unless you
know how critical I am on horror movies
how I always say there's no
horror movies
um this is I'll just give you a quick
synopsis then I want to talk about it
but two years after she escaped a
violent attack on her family Becky
attempts to rebuild her life in the care
of an older woman a kindred spirit named
Elena but when a group known as the
nobleman
break into their home attack them and
take her beloved dog Diego Becky must
return her old ways to protect herself
and her loved ones Lulu Wilson is genius
you're a genius the whole cast is genius
it's like
you know when you mix comedy and horror
you're walking a really it's a thin line
it's like oh you know it could be too I
was just talking to your publicist
Camellia who's awesome and I was just
saying you know that you know sometimes
you get these guys they're just they
just want to make it funny and be goofy
and it takes you out and this didn't it
never took me out of the movie man
that's awesome it was like yeah it was
like those three guys and the old guy
they have these conversations but when
they get brutal
it's dark it is dark and you're
like yeah stay there stay there and your
character I haven't seen you play a
character like that but you're so
reserved and very like oh my God this
guy's gonna snap sometime uh who's he
gonna snap on it was just very well
thought out the dialogue was good
um you know little things like of of her
what's her character's name again Becky
Becky yeah I just it's in the
title you idiot
um no but Becky Becky like you know
she's in the scene and she's she's a
waitress and this guy says darling and
kind of belittles her and she's looking
at him like huh and then she slits his
throat in a certain way I don't want to
give it anyway which I just did but then
you realize it's just in her mind that
idea you're like oh but it's so vicious
and you think things are gonna happen
you're like oh this is gonna happen and
it doesn't and when it gets going like
if you like movies like there's this
movie sisu
[Music]
it's brilliant and this has this it's in
the same vein it's in the same vein as
that's in the same vein of nobody with
Bob Odenkirk who I love who he came on
the podcast yeah I haven't seen that but
that looked great ah dude and it's like
it's just really fun to watch and it's
got some shocking moments and some
Hilarious Moments and and the lead
characters she's she's so good and she's
like so good it really thank you for
saying I'm so glad that I swear I want
to say it I felt the same way when I
watched it because
um you know for me I think I only shot
for like one week and and all my stuff
is in one location so there's so much
that they shot that I didn't see and um
so it was such a treat to watch and I
was like holy everything you just
said it worked because you know when
you're shooting these smaller movies and
the movie doesn't look small at all but
um you never know yeah and you're like
you don't know you know you just and it
was one of those experiences too that
you know just creatively and personally
you know these smaller movies like was
just really fulfilling you know you're
kind of you have a close group of people
like it's a smaller crew and
um so you go like all right well the
experience was fantastic
um if it works then great but when I
watched it it was everything you just
said it was like it was such a tight
movie and they uh Matt Angel and Suzanne
the writer directors they nailed the
tone I want to work with them you tell
them I want to be in a movie with those
guys they know what they're doing I will
definitely tell them they would love
that they know what they're doing and
you know I mean I wonder if like when
they sent you the script because the
script's great but I bet there's one
part of it that you that's the reason
you took the role
can I say can I can I guess can I guess
yeah it's the monologue you tell them
about squeezing the guy oh yeah well
it's a good story to that because
um yeah so they sent me the scripture I
hadn't seen the first Becky and I
actually hadn't worked for almost a year
because I was doing a TV show and you
know how it is you're like in a weird
holding pattern and it kind of you
with like other projects
and so then this thing came around and I
had like a little window and when I read
the script I loved the script and the
the part I just I guess it I couldn't
figure out really how what to do with it
and then it just had some ideas and I
wanted to see if they'd be open to hear
my ideas and they were and so
you know one of them they had a
monologue in there but I said what if
the guy you know because with that
monologue and you don't have that much
time that you spend with this character
is like here's an opportunity to really
share who this guy is create more of a
threat
um and get an idea of his history so it
just raises the stakes and I just said
if he had you know there was you know x
uh Army Ranger
that whole monologue came it was like a
combination of like
you know it was a real collaboration and
I shared these ideas and they were so
awesome about it they rewrote that
monologue and when I read I was like
yeah like that was it for me and
that really informed the rest of the
characters so the character became quite
different than what was on the page and
again it was like
you know never having a chance to do
something like this it was really
fantastic to have filmmakers that
believed in me and believed in some of
these ideas and it made it
um
that just made it a great experience and
then you know to hear you know someone
like yourself like liked it
it was uh it was a treat because you
never know anything like this I know and
you're right about character it's like a
lot of times they'll just have oh these
are bad guys but when you have backstory
when you have backstory um subtext to a
character and you have a little insight
to what he can do it makes everything
more every you just kind of go oh oh oh
this guy yes got a dark side and it just
doesn't Skip by that beat it I love that
beat it's it's important for the movie
and yeah it's it's really good I mean
there's some great lines there's like I
always love like when I watch Return of
the Living Dead one of my favorite
movies it's hilarious it's dark but like
there's all these lines in it that I
just remember
um and like there's there's lines like
uh you know she says one of the
characters says I guess you guess you
missed my brain
oh yeah I was just like holy yeah
that is
that is awesome you guys also
see it I'm not gonna wait yeah how about
when um uh sorry to cut you off but like
one of my favorites though is when um
The Twig character
um
when he's like he's on the ground he's
like I promise I'll stop saying bad
things about women like I have a kid
give it up please and and she's just
about to kill him she goes what's his
name what's his son's name his
performances according to games he's
like
it's Adolf and it was just like yeah
yeah I'm gonna teach my son morals I'm
gonna teach him I'm gonna make sure he
does he's a good boy what's your son's
name Adolf
like he's raising a Nazi yeah I I died
that's I mean there's all there's so
many little gems in there
and it's dark if you're a horror fan
you're gonna love it if you like comedy
you're gonna love it it's just uh shot
well the acting's great I mean it's like
you know another one of these things I'm
a big fan of the movie goon I mean I
know a lot of people are oh that's
awesome dude I'm a huge hockey fan I've
played my whole life I play every Monday
night I have a friends who are in the
NHL I'm just I love hockey and
um that movie was I I know why everyone
loved it so much I know I became this
cult thing uh you know and thank you did
you you play you must have played hockey
no no I played baseball basketball
football my a lot of my friends play
hockey but oh yeah because the
character's not supposed to really have
played hockey because you could see in
the movie I think he was supposed to be
a better skater though I don't think he
was supposed to be a hockey player but I
just remember when I met with Jay bear
shell and Evan Goldberg and Mike Dallas
um and I lied hard I was like
yeah I can skate they're like sure you
just get like ah come on grew up in
Minnesota of course I could skate oh my
God we get up to to you know two weeks
before we're supposed to start shooting
the the movie and I did um we had skate
you know camp
and then when they saw me and I was like
ankle skating I I don't even think they
were so nice to not even say like what
the
it just I think there's just like a
quiet understanding of like oh I guess
we're gonna have to tweak the character
a little bit because the only time I
could stop is if I skated right into the
boards so they just Incorporated that
into the character but kind of worked
for it I think but those scenes like the
scenes with was his name uh leave
Schreiber
um just incredible you both like go
toe-to-toe you're such different
personalities in the movie but you're
both so tough and I will buy it and
there's this just it's just such if you
haven't seen goon I don't know where you
are because it's another one but I but
it's funny because you know somebody
goes Michael Rosemont first they say you
know who's that uh but you know but I
will say you know they'll say oh this
but you have so many moments and so many
good movies like the scene in Old School
is one of the if not my favorite moment
in the movie and most people's that's
awesome they're moving will feral and
it's just like
um you know when you get these
opportunities and you're on the set with
Will Ferrell I guess those nerves are
coming in right you're you're definitely
like oh my God I gotta be good I gotta
be great I got how many takes do
you do with on something like that
oh man also Vince Bond was on set too so
it was like oh God holy man you got
these two giants you know they're like I
don't want to let these guys down but
that
that was hard
um to not I think that what helped me to
not up takes was
I didn't want to disappoint will I
didn't want to screw up what he was
doing so tried to stay in it
um
but the good thing was that my character
is entertained by what remember I think
he because I think once he shoots
himself in the neck with a dart I'm like
that's awesome and so I was able
to at least if I if I had to play it
straight it would have been impossible
because he was adding stuff he was
adding like
you know I like you
but you're crazy I didn't think even
that hit the line that he added that it
kind of gets lost as he walks away and
he's like so tired yeah yeah I'm so
tired I'm super tired dude it's so funny
that I mean I want to watch that scene
again you know what I'm talking about
Ryan of course it's just one of the most
memorable scenes in comedy history and
you're so shocking too because you know
what you don't expect the gun to go off
you know he's kind of looking at it and
yeah oh what what did you say to him you
go that's awesome yeah yeah and
then and I think
Phillips too right I mean he's just like
such a brilliant filmmaker but
um and it was his idea
taught to like slow down the vocals but
the other line too like you better pull
that out man cool down
the door you're gonna dirt
internet
so when you shot that you had no idea it
was going to be slow motion you're like
oh this would be kind of funny and when
you saw it it's a hundred times funnier
than it would ever have been
I couldn't believe it I mean I thought
it was funny but like yeah and when they
did that it was like it just changed
everything
It's the funniest scene in the movie
now that I think of it no there's some
funny scenes in Netflix
he's running around naked and blue and
yeah oh there's a lot of great stuff but
that is just that it's an epic scene and
you know you went on to host SNL which
is the biggest dream of my life and as a
kid you probably
I mean when they ask you to do SNL host
it would you set what obviously said yes
but what was you what were you feeling I
couldn't well it was a mixture of like
because again this is kind of the
beginning and I was like
I was I think I couldn't believe it and
then it was full Panic oh yeah it was
like holy like I can't believe this
and I was like
I don't know if I can do it I've never
done anything like live TV I never you
know
I was oh I was so I was that was the
most
scared I've ever been but it was after a
few weeks after 9 11.
and I remember my friend my best friend
saying like because I was like I'm we I
think we're doing press for like one of
the second American Pie movie
and I was so like nervous about SNL he's
like listen there has never been a more
important time to try to make people
laugh
so I just leaned into that but that
whole week I don't think I ate any I
didn't eat anything I was so stressed
but then when
when we did it that you know you do I
think two performances ones taped a
little bit earlier
and then you just like you say there's
only two ways to go either commit or
you're in this awful like limbo world
where if you're making the entire
country uncomfortable because they can
see your fear but uh yeah yeah it was an
incredible experience but yeah I
couldn't believe it
you know and isn't maybe I'm wrong but
isn't like Will Ferrell the greatest
Will Ferrell moments isn't your moment
in there on his the best one of them
yeah because oh my God like
when we did the rehearsal board I think
like the dress rehearsal
yeah it's in the office scene right and
he's like wearing a patriotic like flag
or whatever yeah like but they're like
Speedos I think yeah and uh
when we did the dress rehearsal he
he propped his leg up and you can see
his balls his leg inside of his leg was
like all like a raw steak it was
crazy and because he was training for a
marathon I think and he got he chat
and so when we did the thing on on live
TV his balls were out I mean he was
balls were there
his she had a weird raw steak leg it was
really hard to not and you don't see
that on film you don't see any of that
no no but I think that's why I mean also
he's hilarious so but if you watch that
scene I think Horatio is laughing Amy
pullers in it like
because I think part of it is like his
little ball was like I'm sorry am I
saying will has a little ball but like
but his balls were hanging out just
saying hello you know I I remember when
I was a kid this is a complete
non-sequitur I was on the couch with my
dad and he just was swimming and he had
these little blue trunks on and he's
just sitting there watching the Mets
sitting on a towel and I looked over and
I saw one of his shiny balls and I just
remember going Dad one of your balls is
hanging out of your pants and instead of
going Jesus Christ
he turned it on me he got so mad
he blew up he goes
you're dead you know go to your go to
your room get out of here you
animal get out they are not your balls
it was like it was funny I was like why
why are you yelling at me they were
you're bossing me and your pants show
you get out of here
bet funny I swear to God my dad
was so like what did you feel afterwards
did you go inside in your room you're
like I go what did I I remember
going upstairs no I remember and I close
slammed my door and the lock always fell
off the handle always fell off cheap
and I remember going
I'm gonna get off camera this what did I
do
did he respond no I came down like two
hours later and he didn't make eye
contact me the rest of the day and it
was weird but he was weird like that
he's really like
you know he didn't like to talk about
private parts and like to tell you I
never saw him naked nor would I want to
I never like there's a lot of stuff it
was just my parents were very kind of
closed off they didn't share that stuff
they didn't you know but if something
was with me they would throw it
at me you know like my grandpa my my
grandpa Lou had this giant sack like uh
I don't know if it was elephantitis or
whatever but I remember in the car with
them on the ride I don't know why I'm
talking about this but I remember on the
car ride home with my parents back to
Indiana I go hey Dad what's with Grandpa
loose balls he goes show some respect
for your grandfather
and then I go sorry my mom goes it's not
even his grandfather she's like on
Valium and stuff she's like it's not
even just I go what my dad's like don't
let's not talk about this what are you
doing and my mom's like
when your grandmother was young her
father left her and then Lou came into
the picture big ball Lou
and I go I go oh sweet so he's not my
biological okay so I'm not gonna get
these big nuts that was my fear that I
was gonna get these big balls
have you done anything with with your
family I mean this story is hilarious I
mean I write all this stuff down but
this is going to be my graphic novel for
sure either that or it's going to be in
a movie it's like it's my parents
growing up you would not believe the
that I went through the therapy you
could only imagine did you ever go to
therapy I know listen I read I read that
you know you're not a private per you're
a private person you don't you know and
you're very open and cool but have you
like we talk about mental health in this
podcast and like you know the stigma of
not going to therapy and all that stuff
we're trying to break that and have you
ever had therapy or have you ever talked
to anybody
yeah you know what
um
a while ago actually after filming goon
I was like I
I hadn't well before goon I had lost my
dad and my dad passed away and then the
other family members like four or five
family members passed away like
maybe in a short period of time it was
like a year or two years and I'm like a
you know very upbeat positive optimistic
person and when that happened it was
like
I I was so I mean obviously it was just
devastated and then I just thought I'd
lost like how am I ever gonna get that
um joy for life back you know I always
thought like I don't even talk to
anybody because I know I'm sad you know
like what am I gonna just repeat what I
know and then finally I was like I
really needed to talk to I really needed
grief counseling
um because
it wasn't it wasn't you know I wasn't
okay and I mean it just it brought you
know I got kind of my life back you know
so but yeah I'm a big advocate for
for talking to therapists and
professionals because it really it
helped me a lot yeah that's all thanks
for sharing that man that's just it just
it opens the door for a lot of people
who are you know listening in the um
you know my dad's one of them he just
won't go to therapy I remember I lost my
uh sister she she was she was very sick
her whole life so she was she grew up in
a children's hospital pretty much and
um you know it was always a matter of
when is she gonna pass because we knew
it was just it was one of those things
she could have she should have died when
she was born that sick but she didn't
and um when she finally passed
um you know my dad I've never seen him a
mess and it broke my heart and I
remember saying Hey listen uh you know
you should think about therapy I was
like oh you think anybody can relate uh
losing a daughter and I go not to be an
but yeah uh people lose
daughters and sons and families and
planes and all this stuff you're not
alone and like if you go talk to someone
you'll see that and it might it might
help you help my friend Chris when he
lost his mom
like exponentially
and so you know but it's for some people
it's that old school mentality they're
like I think they're sure they feel
shame or whatever and it's silly it's
silly it's like you know if if you're
sad and you can't deal with it you're
not figuring it out if you talk to
someone who trains their whole life to
to you know help you through things you
might want to just give it a shot
sometimes a run isn't enough yeah that
was my thing I was like I I know that
I'm sad because I'm like obviously like
my mom you know suggests like maybe it's
maybe you could benefit from talking to
somebody and I was like
I already know how I feel and then I
remember the first meeting with the
grief counselor it was like
uh it was healing just that one meeting
you know so I think it maybe takes just
for somebody who needs some help
um the one that one experience because
um then all of a sudden they could
realize like oh it's also being able to
share things with somebody who's
um not connected to you you know who's
independent and obviously you know
experienced in a professional yeah yeah
no I love I love that you open up about
that that's really cool look you've done
so much I mean I can go on about like
you know Dude Where's My Car which was a
big success and the final destinations
and Dukes of Hazard which was actually a
huge success that actually that made a
lot of freaking Hazard huh we like to
Johnny Knoxville and I you'd like to
call it the Dixon Hazard the Dukes of
Hazard yeah I like that I like that and
I work with Bo Duke he was my uh Clark
Kent's father on on Smallville
yeah that's awesome John Schneider but
um like I'm looking over here it's like
you know you voice crash and Ice Age and
you're constantly working you've done so
much and you know we'd have to we have
to just bring it up but Stifler and
American Pie franchise is that something
do you still get offers for them like
hey we got another idea we got another
idea do they still throw that at you or
is that kind of doesn't it you're you're
not interested in that anymore
you know what
um no I think
I love that character I I
for a while though I was like uh
especially after the last one you know
we filmed in like 2011 or 12 and I was
like okay this is a great bookend to
this character you know
um I didn't think I didn't think it'd be
fun to play the character again and then
as time went on I was like and as the
world has changed and I thought that
seeing that character today
um could be really interesting and we've
started I saw Jason Biggs not long ago
we shot a commercial
um and this is like a couple weeks ago
and we were just kind of talking about
some ideas because we thought it would
have to be it would have to be a perfect
idea it would have to you know because
obviously so much has changed comedies
have changed and but
I think I again the thing about that
character too is that when it comes to
comedies like that character allowed me
to do so much
you know you could be he could like say
so many things that were inappropriate
but yet you still kind of loved him and
there was like physical comedy and all
sorts of stuff that I don't really get a
chance to do with other characters so
even just selfishly you know I think
that would be fun but I don't know I
don't I don't know if they'll ever
because
that's yeah I think comedies have
changed so much that that movie would
have to change and adapt and you know be
more relatable
um so we'll see maybe Stifler has an
identity or a gender identity crisis and
he's like
I think so and then you're the censor
are you out of your freaking mind you're
a man what are you talking about
and yeah that's the movie you just you
just cracked the code come on
[Laughter]
there's a million ideas out there but um
dude it's it's so awesome talking to you
I mean it's like you know it's endless
and it's like you know then talking to
you what a great guy you are and this
movie
but by the way The Rock Dwayne Johnson
do you like have him on speed dial do
you like can you talk call him whenever
you want I wish no no I haven't I
haven't spoken to him in a while but I
mean
but obviously I watch all these movies
but you know that's another one of those
those like moments where
I always tell them something I can't
believe I got to work with the guy twice
actually on Southland Tales but um man
that was one of the best experiences
shooting The Rundown that was awesome
who who have you been uh intimidated by
or when they come on set as an actor
that you've worked with that you're in
awe or enamored or is your idol or
anybody a lot I mean
um me too yeah I'm always intimidating
you know I was like yeah I remember like
Billy Bob's I mean and these are all
incredible people but when you know
first meeting them was like Susan
Sarandon and Billy Bob Thornton on Mr
Woodcock or Christopher Walken in the
rundown
um Julianne Moore David Duchovny and
evolution
um Dan Aykroyd and evolution I mean
there's
you know the rock uh like yeah there's
been so many big stars that
um Charlie and fat and Bulletproof Monk
you know where I'm just like
uh and usually for the most part it was
always the part of me that's you know
because I'm a film fan so you know
throughout the experience of shooting
those movies I was still always just
like kind of nervous well you did a
movie that was produced by Keanu Reeves
was he ever on set did you ever get to
talk to him
no never mind I know hey Sean great job
really love the movie I I can imagine
Impressions do you do Impressions you
know I'm terrible how you know nobody I
actually every once in a while like the
random
not people but uh like
like Elmo Gollum you know those weirdos
yeah I can't do it right now I I no I'm
not gonna ask you to do I'm not going to
ask you to do Elmo or that I mean if you
did a Nicholson or something I'd ask you
to do Elmo dude you don't want a clip of
your own hey everybody you don't wanna
you don't want that clip you'll throw up
on your screen I wouldn't want to put it
in the podcast it's just like you know
it's embarrassing let's cut that Ryan
let's cut the Elmo thing it's cool but
not yeah
it's not cool Ryan we're gonna we're
gonna make Sean look good we want him to
be look you know and um how do you stay
healthy by the way do you uh do you work
out a lot do you run a lot do you I mean
what is it that you you keep in uh how
you keep in shape
I'm you know I
um road bike
and one of those guys you know like the
uh it's funny because like the BMX dirt
like kind of on the
you know like the skinny like road bikes
just like you see are you do you live in
California yeah okay
um PCH and so I used to like make fun of
them they'd all wear like the same
little outfits and stuff and they're
like weird bikes and um and then you
know my buddy introduced me to it and I
was like holy uh I love it so I'm
wearing the outfit I got the weird you
know butt padded like onesie thing and
um so that's my thing now
I don't have a good enough body I
wouldn't do it they go that they think I
was Gollum seriously in that tight or
like what's his name uh who who Andy
Circus in that you know when he's doing
all the movement uh this is called
talking with Sean William Scott
um this is rapid fire these are my
patrons top tier they're loyal they're
gonna they're gonna love you because
you're awesome uh but uh patreon.com
inside of you if you want to get back to
the podcast keep it going rozzy have you
ever been struck star struck by someone
you have worked with we mentioned that
but who's the biggest one who's the one
that you're like that I've worked with
yeah
man Sean say me it was me I was gonna
say Christopher Walken for sure yeah he
was intimidating because he's also I
mean he's just awesome but he's uh he's
also intimidating he is he is oh yeah I
remember uh
we I just would watch him on set when he
was working on this movie pool hall
junkies this little independent and I I
remember
just the way he said lines like the line
was they're playing pool and he says
you know they're gambling and he goes
you know bed at all
and he goes
and then walk and says how about the
ring Joe he says how about the ring he
wants his ring
and and Paul materi says
the ring you want the ring
and I remember walking if you read the
line it would have been like well you
said it Joe bet it all you said it and
he goes you said it Joe
did it all
right
just the way you said it Joe bet it all
just it goes down it goes up it's just
like what the is he doing and it's
genius and he's like he was weird he was
weird but I loved him but he with
me hard on uh The Rundown uh what did he
do there's three times that I remember
the one I've told the story before but
like I remember just walking off from
said and I saw him I think standing in
front of his trailer he just kind of
gotta looks sad and I was like man I
can't question for walking looking sad
by his trailer so I walked over to him
and I and forgive me because I had I
have told a story before but it helps
with the other ones but like I didn't
know what to call him like Chris or
Christopher wait a minute I I told the
story
did you flash
yeah did you just say did you say his
full name
yes I said I sort of got it I said are
you go tell the story tell it sorry for
interrupting but no no no but yeah I I
saw I would always call him Christopher
Walken
did you call him Christopher Walken no
Tell Your Story start over I'm gonna cut
that out cut that out Jason I'm an
say it again go ahead no no so
as I walked up to him and I was like
hey Christopher Walken are you okay and
he goes
I can't do his voice so let's do mine
but he's like yeah I am I'm good I'm
good
I'm a little sad you know it's my
birthday so I'm like holy dude it's
your birthday I'm god get these
people to get you a cake or something
he's like no no no
I don't want a kid
I'm just kidding it's not my birthday
I'm like what because yeah it's not my
birthday I was like what the away
and then like an hour later I hear
people singing Happy Birthday
and bringing him a cake
oh no he what he said was he goes
because it's not my I didn't I didn't
say we got to get him a cake he goes
when he admitted it wasn't his birthday
he goes no it's not my birthday I'm like
he was like I bet you if I told people
it was they'd bring me a cake so that's
when like an hour later I heard people
saying happy birthday and bringing him a
cake and he looks you look past it and
he gets he Winks at me like what the
so the second thing that happened
was he came over to me we were on set
and and Dwayne was unsaid and he goes
walks up to me and he'd always go hey
dude
and and I was like oh hi Crystal Walker
he goes do you know where I can get a a
nice Steam and I was like
um a steam he was yeah I would like to
get a nice Steam
so I said yeah hold on a second all
right went up to Dwayne I go hey dude um
Christopher Walken wants a steam do you
know where where he could get that he's
like
how am I supposed to know where to get a
steam I go I'm sorry you're right so
then somebody told me of like a spot
um I go um Christopher Walken um there's
a place called Brook Williams and
apparently they have you know a place
where you could get a nice Steam and he
goes
do you think to be a lot of pretty men
there and I'm like
I'm sure I'm sure sure he looked at me
and he winked and he walked away and I
was like
so then like like a couple weeks later
he walked up to me and he goes the
Rolling Stones are playing this October
I'm like holy hold on a sec I go up
to Dwayne go dude Christopher Walken
wants to go to The Rolling Stones with
us they're playing this October
and Dwayne looks at me goes
um dude it's it's November
and then I went over Crystal and then he
looked at me and winked and he just
walked away that's what he would do all
the time he was just with Sean
William Scott but the funniest part is
Christopher Walken like who the fact
that you're calling Christopher with me
it was just quick I went up to him I
said I was nervous I should call you Mr
Walken should I call you um uh Chris he
goes I don't know just call me flash
and the next day I tell the story many
times and I just said hey to my friend
Anthony Hanson watch this hey flash
nothing flash nothing finally tensor
goes what are you talking
what are you talking and walked away I
was like what the is going on
here oh see you did the same thing with
you he messed he with me too but
he with you a lot more hard yeah
he he you hard that didn't
that didn't sound right uh real quick
stone age uh hey Sean Dukes of Hazzard
is one of my all-time favorite movies
what's your experience working like on
the film how fun was it worth to work
with Johnny Jessica Willie Nelson big
fan
that's awesome
um it was a ball also Burt Reynolds was
it was amazing man he's a legend so it
was one of the most fun experiences I've
had in um Johnny Knoxville's just uh one
of the best he's a great guy I think my
my buddy Dax actually said uh
because I used to call we used to call
him like burnt rentals like just just
not for nothing no other reason than
instead of Bert rentals rentals we say
hey brunch rentals so he was working
with him like a lot and they were
working a lot together and finally one
day goes burnt rentals what's up he goes
yeah don't don't call me that again
and that was it
he thought he could just do it he was
like no uh Lex during the filming of
Jackass 3D did any of those guys prank
you off camera no but I was I was ready
for it but I think because I was I I
gained a bunch of weight for goon and
they didn't know that so I think that
they all looked at me like um poor guy
you know he's kind of chunky so I think
it helped me to you know otherwise I
think they probably would have done
something nasty
probably been in better shape did he did
Johnny ever play any kind of prank on
you or did I mean is there any kind of
fun story that you haven't told that
that you just you can't tell she I I
think it was I kind of made it I think I
told him right at the beginning like I
really please don't like with me
I don't want to be stressed out I'm
trying to do a good job of this movie
but I don't want to be thinking like
something up is gonna happen he
was very respectful to that but I I
don't know why I keep thinking this one
moment but we were shooting at
somebody's Farm
he's like the family from the bar that
owned the farm we're kind of watching uh
us shoot the scene and they were
standing kind of off the side and there
was like big family he was like the
grandpa the dad the mom the kids
and Johnny walks over by them
and I kind of saw him standing next to
next to the whole family and then I
looked away and I hear this shine
and look over and he's got his ball
stretched out through his his pants but
nobody can Nobody Knows the family
doesn't know so they're just all
standing and he's just in there looking
at him like what
I mean that's not even shocking to hear
at all but it's brilliant it was so
crazy he like stretched it out he just
let it dangle there and I was like
it is it just for me just for me to you
know feel uncomfortable and you know
laugh check out my bubble gum Sean check
out my bubble gum my bubble gum balls
you know what's funny as I remember we
wrote this movie uh uh like years ago 10
years ago and we had all these people
attaching I oh and I always wanted you
as the role we could the movie ended up
not getting mad we were in prep and we
were scouting but I always wanted you as
the lead I was directing it was like
John heater and Seth Green and uh what
happened with it uh we never made it but
it was called sorry is for sissies and
it's about a guy who was a bully in high
school
but he then gets expelled but changes
his whole life and he's like in this
newfound guy but nobody knows him he
just leaves town and this guy's sister
is marrying him and and he hasn't met
the guy because you know he hasn't seen
his sister in a while and they go back
to this one and he goes he realizes this
is the guy that picked him you're
marrying on the guy who picked on
tortured me and my friends and he
blackmails the guy to go on a road trip
of redemption to apologize to everybody
he met he tortured or you know whatever
or he's gonna tell his sister everything
so the guy goes hey your brother and I
are going on this road trip with his
other friend and it's just hijinks out
the ass a road trip of craziness and the
kid has no intention of ever like
letting his sister marry this guy which
you find out but he finally proves
himself in a way but it's it was
ridiculous idea what happened why did
you make it we just never we just never
can get it financed again we had to
financially lost the financing but we
loved it and I always said Sean William
Scott like that guy could play
dark as you see the past and he could
see the the comedic part but he's the
straight guy but he's like it's just but
that you were the guy I swear to God
thanks for thinking of me I wish we had
done that movie you could still make
that movie I know I'm sorry it's for
Sissy's man but I always remember I and
I didn't wasn't thinking about it till
just now oh my God that's right my other
riding Partners were like that's the guy
I'm like what about me you know but uh
dude this has been epic I can't thank
you enough
um thank you thanks for having me on man
it's been so much fun I'm really
grateful yeah and uh Wrath of Becky is
is gonna be streaming everywhere you
have to see it it's dark it's funny it's
it's a performance I haven't seen in you
and I'm like you're so capable of doing
really anything and you should you
should be doing everything in and
everything anything and what else are
you doing what show are you doing now
well by the way thank you so much for
everything you said I really it means a
hell of a lot I mean buddy I mean it I
mean I know you do it man it's a huge
compliment I really really appreciate it
um
thank you
um I'm doing well I did a TV show I
don't know if they're gonna do a third
season but it's uh Paul feek produced it
called uh welcome to flatch but you know
what's interesting is like actually
because you were talking about movies
that I've done but I haven't really done
much uh over the last like
six plus years because a lot of the
stuff that has been sent to me is like
ah great and I'm like I'd rather not I'd
rather just pick things that I feel you
know I could be proud of but now
um it's it's a kind of a moment in my
career that I've never had where there's
a few things that are really all very
interesting and and allow me a few
different projects that allow me to you
know do different you know show a
different side you know kind of like
wrath and Becky that you never know with
these movies you know there's four
things that are lined up and none of
them could happen but um so we'll see
but right now I'm just like I'm happy to
be in a movie
that I'm actually proud of yeah and I'm
actually really happy and proud that I
liked it as well
I mean I am because it wasn't one of the
fun comfortables not it was not fun
comfortable it was entertaining from the
beginning to the end I liked everybody
the performances it's shocking it's uh I
know like I'm thinking about like some
of my patrons who like love horror
movies too and I'm like Raj
you're gonna love this and you know it's
definitely a horror movie it's not a
horror movie it's like this dark
dramatic comedy it's almost it's a
horror but it's got that horror element
in it because there's some gruesome
stuff but it's it's warranted it's like
oh my God
yeah it's really cool so yeah it's like
you know what
um
it kind of is like it's like if if
Uma Thurman from Kill Bill had a kid
with John Wick
right and it's uh it's because it's God
like it's almost like a little bit of a
16 year old Kill Bill Vibe and a little
bit of Edgar Wright kick ass you know I
think that's what the filmmakers were
kind of going for but yeah I think he
likes those movies I 100 see that but uh
Wrath of Becky and uh continued success
man I hope you come back on another time
uh bug Camellia next time you have a
project you got to come on and talk
about it or whatever I love to sit with
you again this is great that would be
great thank you so much I really
appreciate it
great guy I couldn't believe how he just
so he's so nice and he's private and he
opened up a little for sure but he was
just really kind just a kind guy just
like yeah yeah you know just you know
just having a conversation and
um
uh it's it's nice I mean he's had a
great career and he's done a lot and he
saw that he wanted to change it up a bit
after American Pie and he's getting cast
in a lot of roles we talk about the Will
Ferrell scene yeah and um old school
right it was old school where he uh
uh he's I get he shoots Will Ferrell
shoots himself with the tranquilizer in
the neck and he's like oh my God was
that bad and everything gets slow-mo
she's like oh my God it's so funny it's
one of the funniest scenes I've ever
seen anywhere you have to see you
haven't seen old school no watch that
scene on YouTube at least
it's amazing will do
um thanks for listening as you know I'll
be in Montreal with Tom Welling doing a
Smallville nights Montreal get your
tickets this weekend
um the 15th 14th 15th 16th that weekend
which is this coming weekend because
this air is Tuesday and uh make sure you
listen to the podcast spread the word
subscribe if you're if you enjoyed this
one I appreciate it patreon.com inside
you to support the podcast and keep us
going if you're if you're digging this
and right now without further Ado why
don't we get into the top tier patrons
this is another perk you get your name
read off and we're also doing some more
perks for Patron that Bryce and I are
working on to make it even more
appealing and give back a little more
someone asked me do you write the little
notes that you every couple months the
boxes I'm like
yeah of course Sarah who would write
that I write them and I I it's not just
like hey thanks bye Michael it's like I
write a note
to each person yeah you guys matter you
matter to me all right here we go and me
Nancy D Leah K little Lisa you Kiko Jill
e Brian H Nico P Robert B J there's it's
Brandenburg
Robert oh hang on what did I say in the
beginning Robert I think I said
Brandenburg I believe that's it yeah
great
uh support that guy Jason W Sophie M
Jason Weaver Dreamweaver Raj C I'll
never pronounce your last name Ron so I
just won't never be able to do it
foreign
Joshua D Jennifer and Stacy l
what was that song Stacy's Mom's got it
going this is Mama's got it going on yes
she does Jamal
F Janelle B Mike E El Dan Supremo 99
more San Diego am San Diego waiting for
my sorority boys
um statues and my Lex Luthor statue
you're amazing thanks for all the hard
work
um he he helped make these little uh
inside of you figurines of me we still
have like five online on the inside of
you online Source it's me he made the
little little glasses come off and
details the details and then he did the
busts that are amazing The Lex Luthor
busts yes see that big one yeah those
are wild well he he made smaller ones
that are dope with a little Smallville
box like a little Corp just like that
though as detailed there's only one left
so it might be sold by the time this is
over Chad W Leanne P Maya P got me a Red
Bull once at a convention because I was
tired very nice smile madius Melinda and
Dave Hall well oh Michael it's Dave hole
I've heard you guys I love dating cool
I've heard you guys love Dave I love
Dave Hall Sheila G
Betsy D we're going to be doing a zoom
soon
uh zooms you can get zooms on the
sunspin band.com or sunspin.com you can
get all sunspin merch are albums are up
and on vinyls available autographed on
the sunspin.com remind me to say that to
add to the beginning
Corey K devnex and Michelle a angel
amerian and C Jeremy C Brandy d y vore
what for yavar Joey M Eugene and Leah I
still owe them something their baby was
crying at a thing at the con Smallville
nights and I had to kick kick them out
yeah well Eugene stayed and Leah suffer
with the baby
Heather L shout out Leah shout out to
Leah Jake B Angela F Mel s Caroline R
Christine s Eric a chain R Andrew M Tim
L Oracle Amanda R Jen B Kevin e
Stephanie K jorel jam and J Leanne J
Luna R Mike F Stone H Brian L Aaron R
Kendall L Meredith I kerosi Jessica B
Kyle f
we got Marisol wonderful Marisol p and
wonderful Andrew M and Estevan G
Kaylee J Brian a Ashley F Marion Louise
L Romy of the band Veronica Q Frank B
gen T Nikki L and April r
thank you guys thank you newcomers thank
you old comers
thank you everybody thank you everybody
for sure uh and that's all I really have
to say thank you patrons patreon.com
anxiety Jason thanks for being here
great to be here thanks for having me
yeah always a pleasure from Michael
Rosenbaum in the Hollywood Hills of
California I'm Jason Elkin
Ryan tez is not here
we love you a little way to the camera
we love you be good to yourself we'll
see you later
foreign